-We don't always have
enough time
to cover all of the recent news,
so here with a recap
is one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin, in a segment
we call "Amber Says What."
♪♪
-You guys!
Things. have. been. crazy.
Okay, so, recently,
the state of Texas
had a winter emergency
and I was like, "What?!
Texas had a winter emergency?
Oh, Lord, we done
broke the Earth!"
Then, I found out that this
caused millions of Texans
to go without heat or water
and I was like, "What?!"
Then, I found out that it was
at this exact moment
that Texas Senator Ted Cruz
chose to go to Cancún
and I was like, "What?!
Then, he blamed his children
for the trip
and I was like, "What?!"
Then, I found out
he left his dog at home
and I was like, "What?!"
[ Laughter ]
How could you leave
a dog at home
when you, sir, also are a dog?
Now, I know everyone rags
on you a ton, Ted,
but maybe it's not enough?
Look at that dog!
Poor thing!
How bad do you have
to have it to miss Ted Cruz?
[ Laughter ]
Dang!
Then, something
really cute happened!
Okay, so this extra fluffy sheep
was found in the wild
and they ended up shaving
78 pounds of wool from it.
And I was like, "What?!"
Well, it's a good thing
you got a haircut,
because your hair
was getting too long!
Hey, Seth, did you hear
what I said to the sheep?
-Yeah.
-I said that its hair
was too long.
-Yeah.
-I suggested
that it get a haircut.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I heard what you said.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, Naomi Osaka was
at the Australian Open
when this happened --
-Playing around her.
Yeah, there it is.
-Aww!
-A fan yells out,
"There's a butterfly
on your legs,"
and, now, Osaka's going
to take it to safety.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-I saw that and I was like,
"What?!"
Isn't that cute?
That butterfly is all of us.
We all think Naomi's perfect,
and want to give her
a little kiss on the nose!
And then, when the butterfly
wouldn't leave,
Naomi gently took it
off of her face and set it down!
I saw that and was like,
"What?!"
She is so sweet!
Because, if a butterfly
landed on my face
in the middle of a really
important thing,
I'd have just smashed it
because [bleep] a butterfly.
[ Laughter ]
Then, the funniest thing
in the world happened!
A Texas attorney,
during a trial,
could not get rid
of his Zoom filter. Look.
-Can you hear me, Judge?
-I can hear you.
I think it's a filter.
-It is. I don't know how
to remove it.
I've got my assistant here.
She's trying to, but --
I'm prepared
to go forward with it.
I'm here live.
I'm not a cat.
-I saw that and was like,
"What
are you, if you aren't a cat?
You sure look
like a cat to me."
"I am not a cat."
That's exactly what a cat
would say, you cat-ass cat.
[ Laughter ]
Then, I heard a harrowing tale
of ingenuity and perseverance.
The tale of the
Gorilla Glue Girl.
So, okay, this lady had used
Gorilla Glue to do her hair
and she couldn't get it out!
And then, she was like, "What?!"
And I was like, "What
did you think
was going to happen?"
It's glue.
All it does is glue.
So she went online
and told her story
and everyone was offering
suggestions about what to do.
And I was like,
"What could she possibly do?!"
It's glue.
Glue. gonna. glue.
And then, I, like every other
person who heard this story,
became obsessed with her and I
needed her to be okay, so badly!
She was so sad in the video!
And it's not. her. fault!
We all did crazy things
when we were young!
It's fine!
Then, I found out she's 40!
And I was like,
[ Laughing ] "What?"
[ Laughter ]
Oh, no!
Then, a doctor reached out
to her and said,
"I can remove it for free,"
and I was like, "What?"
But then, he did,
and her hair looked perfect
and I was like, "What?!"
And then, a whole nation
rejoiced, like, "What?! What?!"
Then, I found out that these two
are going to have a second baby
and I was like, "What?!"
Yay! I love it!
But I looked online
and these British people
were so mad at her.
I mean, they've always
been mad at her,
but this time I was like,
"What
are you so mad about,
that this woman is pregnant?"
You're going to be mad
that a man and his wife
are having their second child?
I wonder what it is
about her you don't like.
What could it possibly be
that has those British people
so on edge?
What about her contribution
to the royal bloodline
has them angry?
Well, we may never know.
[ Laughter ]
Then the Britney Spears
documentary came out
and people were all like,
"Free Britney!"
Crying and stuff in the little
"Free Britney" T-shirts.
And I was all like, "What?!"
Then, I watched the movie
and I was like, "What?
Get me a T-shirt!"
So, okay, here's what happens.
Like her dad had control
of her money and stuff
and she refused to perform
until that stopped.
And I was like, "What?!"
Then, it happened.
They went to court and her dad
lost financial control
in her conservatorship
and I was like, "What?!"
Even though I still
don't fully understand
what a conservatorship is.
Like this girl is almost 40
and controls nothing
of her life.
If anyone needs
a conservatorship,
it's Gorilla Glue Lady.
[ Laughter ]
Then everyone was like,
"Did you see
the new United States
Postal Service mail truck?"
And I was like, "What?!
No. Why would I?"
And then, there were like,
"You got to see it."
And I was like, "What?!"
But then I saw it.
I was like,
"What?!
What happened?!"
Did this truck drive through
the space-time continuum?
What is this?
What are you delivering,
the Pope?
Who designed this truck,
Homer Simpson?!
What even is this?!
You know what I think
this truck is?
I -- Oh.
Whoa, wait.
[ Laughter ]
How beautiful!
A butterfly!
I'm going to get it!
[ Clap ]
[ Laughter ]
I got business to do!
I killed it!
This has been "Amber Says What."
♪♪